okay so
let's keep going down the list so we've
got tether that's a coin don't
use that it's really just a stable coin
uh binance coin so bnb is interesting
because um
i had to pick some up i don't know like
six or seven months ago just to do some
staking and a few other side things i'm
doing on
binance and i got it at like 30 bucks
it's 197 dollars today
what the hell is going on with um
finance coin in your view
finance coin is uh a very old-school
type of model it's an exchange coin
that became very popular in 2017
so that you it's a utility token for the
most part you use it for reduced fees on
binance you can use it for staking
to earn some type of fees but for the
most part it acts
similar to as a dividend because instead
of
it acts like a dividend i say but it's
not the same flow as a dividend dividend
they'll actually give you payouts
so in binance's case it don't give you
payouts per se but they burn the supply
of the token
okay um so so the way that i'm using it
kind of like as an elementary you know
description from my experiences
um if you want to stake on projects or
earn tokens if you want to
earn at a stable interest rate um
that's that's basically what you have to
use on um sure
caveat you don't own your keys on
finance so
right that's the one thing yeah so when
you say owning your keys you mean like
you want them on cold storage like you
would store your bitcoin but i mean
you're not going to do that with binance
coin because it's more correct
also also depending on the amount you
want to withdraw i think it's
2 btc but you can correct me if i'm iran
you will have to do you have to do koic
and aml yeah
um which is just a couple of hoops you
got to jump through to get your bitcoin
out if you're moving more than two at a
time
um
you